et donc on commence avec de la
littérature avec un livre qui aborde le
thème de la souffrance au travail selon
le ministère du travail depuis le
covid-19 l'état de santé psychique des
travailleurs c'est fortement dégradé
charge de travail relation avec le
management ou encore quête de sens des
sujets dont Françoise François à
l'habitude de traiter en tant que
psychologue et fondatrice de la maison
souffrance et travail 78 et pour
sensibiliser sur ce sujet elle a écrit
un roman policier intitulé quand
l'horreur est humaine il est inspiré de
fait réel et Françoise François est avec
nous pour en parler le roman commence
fort tout de suite on est plongé dans le
coeur du sujet et Léonore et psychologue
dans la dans cette maison souffrance et
travail et alors elle est empoisonnée on
le disait en début d'émission alors on
suit un petit peu sa fille Jeanne qui
est policière et qui essaye de
comprendre ce qui s'est passé
ce roman je le disais il est inspiré de
deux faits réels alors qu'est-ce
matériel qu'est-ce qui n'est pas réel et
ce que c'est inspiré d'une histoire
d'une de vos collègues de vous qu'est-ce
qui s'est vraiment passé
tout ce qui le lisent posent la même
question en fait
non je dis pas été empoisonné voilà mais
rassuré en même temps l'activité que je
fais enfin que nous faisons parce qu'on
est quand même une dizaine de personnes
dans cette maison
oui on ne se fait pas que des amis dans
ce milieu là donc ça aurait pu être
voilà mais ça n'a pas été alors
j'insiste parce qu'on m'a envoyé du thé
en précisant que ça n'était pas
empoisonné on m'a fait pour comprendre
du coup faudrait à lire le livre
et pourquoi est-ce que vous avez décidé
d'écrire sur ce sujet là en particulier
c'était un besoin d'évacuer de ou de
sensibiliser
alors évacuer pas du tout non
sensibiliser plutôt
sensibiliser parce que la souffrance au
travail reste quand même aujourd'hui
même si on en parle ça démocratise un
tout petit peu mais c'est pas encore le
sujet du jour pour les instances
voilà et
en parler c'était aussi mettre un peu de
lumière sur cette maison sous France et
travail
qui n'a pas de subvention d'État en fait
elle peut vivre grâce au travail des
psychologues en interne voilà et
elle est debout en fait depuis
maintenant 10 ans
et parler un peu de notre métier parce
que en fait c'est aussi ça ça permet de
mettre en visibilité le travail que l'on
fait ça démocratise aussi un petit peu
ça ça des diabolise un petit peu aussi
voilà donc on travaille effectivement en
consultation de face à face avec tous
types de salariés c'est des policiers
c'est des gendarmes c'est des médecins
c'est des soignants c'est des gens du
privé public donc ça nous oblige à nous
de savoir naviguer entre le droit public
et le droit privé
ça nous oblige également à comprendre
les processus en oeuvre les
organisations
voilà ça nous permet aussi d'aller en
entreprise parce qu'on est sollicité par
des chefs d'entreprise
voilà pour régler les conflits faire des
médiations
on est appelé aussi dans des
associations
humanitaires pour faire des supervisions
aux professionnels voilà on est un peu
sur tous les champs en fait
ce livre c'est aussi l'occasion de
mettre des mots alors sur des mots M a u
x des maladies comme la dépression comme
le harcèlement alors ça permet de savoir
ce que c'est qu'un harcèlement alors moi
c'est pas dit clairement quand c'est du
harcèlement par exemple sur on voit
l'histoire si on lit l'histoire de
Charlotte on pourrait penser à un
harcèlement institutionnel et un
harcèlement individuel voilà
Éléonore peut-être qu'elle burn out si
elle se réveille pas c'est peut-être
qu'elle est en burn out ça personne ne
m'en a parlé en tout cas des plus de
1000 lecteurs pour l'instant et au début
moi je me suis demandé si elle tombait
dans les pommes parce que justement elle
avait trop travaillé et voilà mais non
en fait une alarme et empoisonnée
voilà non et Léonore c'est quelqu'un qui
en veut qui se donne
beaucoup même peut-être un peu trop et
si elle a des difficultés à se réveiller
puisque personne n'arrive à dire
pourquoi elle ne se réveille pas c'est
peut-être que elle est épuisée
professionnellement aussi voilà bah du
coup ça permet de voir aussi que quand
on est beaucoup trop investi dans son
travail c'est peut-être là aussi on peut
se mettre en danger psychiquement alors
aussi à travers ce livre on suit des
histoires dramatiques de salariés
histoire de Charlotte histoire de Henry
qui s'est suicidé parce qu'il y avait
trop de pression au travail et ça pour
le coup ce sont des histoires inspirées
de faits réels inspiré de fait réels et
très romancée pour ne pas que voilà en
fait chacun peut s'identifier dans
chacune des histoires puisque c'est un
peu ce qu'on m'a renvoyé comme comme
retour c'est mais je me suis reconnue un
peu dans Charlotte je me suis reconnue
un peu dans Henri moi aussi j'ai eu des
idées noires moi aussi j'ai pensé au
pire voilà
et puis c'est des pères de famille des
mères de famille c'est des gens qui à
côté ont une vie mais qui à un moment
donné oublie cette vie là
et danger
et donc dans ce roman vous l'expliquez
un petit peu tout à l'heure vous mettez
un petit peu en avant le travail le
quotidien qui est fait dans cette maison
souffrance et travail comment est-ce
qu'on fait pour tenir le coup moralement
psychologiquement face à de telles
histoires
je ne sais pas
c'est un mystère c'est vraiment un
mystère bon j'écris effectivement moi je
suis une passionnée de musique dans le
dans le livre on le voit aussi puisque
Éléonore écoute beaucoup de musique
voilà c'est les moyens de cliver en fait
moi je fais de la méditation
je lis un livre très précieux tous les
matins dont je ne vous dirai pas le
titre enfin voilà je suis je suis très
spirituelle donc voilà selon vous la
situation dans les entreprises sur
l'état psychique des salariés se
dégradent aujourd'hui
alors moi je oui je peux je peux tester
de ça puisque je vais aussi en
entreprise voilà
j'ai pour la première fois j'ai eu droit
à un carroshi
un carrossier qu'est-ce que c'est
qu'est-ce que c'est un carrossir un
carrossier en fait c'est quelqu'un qui
meurt d'épuisement au travail
parce que il y a des gens qui font des
métiers où ils sont très peu payés et
donc du coup bah ils sont obligés
d'avoir deux métiers et ils travaillent
à temps plein sur deux métiers avec très
peu d'heures de repos et et le coeur à
un moment donné lâche voilà donc c'est
des gens qu'on a des difficultés à
réanimer voire même qu'on ne peut pas
réanimer
vous vous partagez un peu ce constat
Marianne edwire Alain Cissé que la
situation aujourd'hui sur les conditions
de travail l'état psychique des salariés
au travail se dégradent
vous qui êtes directeur par exemple j'ai
le sentiment c'est vrai que depuis la
covid je pense qu'il y a un effet covid
il y a eu des retours compliqués à
l'issue du confinement il y en a qui
étaient en attente il y en a qui l'ont
très mal vécu moi j'ai des salariés à
l'époque que j'avais dû faire rapatrier
parce que en entreprise
parce que chez eux c'était l'horreur
quoi alors après c'est clair je pense à
notamment à une de mes cadres là une
personne qui va voyager à travers le
monde en non-stop qui se retrouve alors
en plus célibataire
un certain âge toute seule enfermé en
non-stop du lundi jusqu'au dimanche soir
j'ose imaginais la vie de cette femme
donc c'est vrai qu'on a rapidement on
l'a rapidement autorisé à revenir sur
site puisque nous on y était pour la
partie production donc ça derrière je
pense que c'est un impact et puis
l'impact aussi derrière nous c'est vrai
que par moment
on se dit que des fois il y a un peu de
pression et pourquoi il y a beaucoup il
y a de la pression parce qu'on a
beaucoup de commandes et on n'arrive pas
à recruter
et ce problème de recrutement on en a
parlé tout à l'heure enfin on y est
confronté tous les deux bah c'est vrai
que malheureusement au moment donné
quand vous avez de la pression
indéniablement ça ça peut se répercuter
là-dessus quoi la pression au travail
les gens apprennent à la gérer
moi ce que je pointe du doigt c'est pas
tant ça en fait c'est des modes de
management délétères c'est c'est de la
maltraitance en fait et c'est pour ça
que le titre s'appelle quand l'horreur
est humaine c'est que les gens entre eux
c'est pas le travail en lui-même qui
abîme les gens bien sûr il y a des
troubles musculo-squelettiques bien sûr
avoir plus mal au dos à la jambe à la
tête au bras etc mais c'est les
personnes entre elles qui en arrivent à
se faire des choses qui sont pas
tolérables en fait je pense que si
effectivement on se regardait un peu
mieux si on se respecte plus si on
respectait un peu les si on ne serait-ce
que de dire bonjour au revoir merci s'il
te plaît tu as fait du bon boulot
aujourd'hui je t'en remercie enfin c'est
basique mais c'est essentiel pour moi ce
genre de choses voyez la petite pause
café où on va prendre un café de manière
tout à fait informelle et on va se
donner des informations informelles qui
sont essentielles pour la bonne
continuité du travail tout ça là ça
s'oublie dans le travail et aujourd'hui
c'est j'en parlais tout à l'heure on en
parlait tout à l'heure au ministère de
la santé c'est c'est pas parce qu'on va
mettre une petite salle de repos pour
les soignants que les soignants vont
s'autoriser à aller dans la petite salle
de repos parce que ils ont quand même
d'autres choses à faire c'est à dire
qu'il y a une perf à poser il y a un
soin à donner voilà et dans des
conditions plutôt tendues on va pas se
le cacher et bien merci beaucoup
Françoise François d'avoir répondu pour
mettre à nos questions je vous invite à
lire ce livre quand l'horreur est
humaine il est disponible sur le site
internet de la maison souffrance et
travail 78 qui s'affichent en bas de
votre écran mais également sur tout
autre plateforme si vous souhaitez le